[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el tema de
hoy está enfocado en los pacientes
inmunodeprimidos y su proceso de
vacunación contra el kobe 19 nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
asesor científico de france 24 y médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia doctor gracias por
acompañarnos inició preguntándole qué
certeza hay de la eficacia de las
vacunas contra el coi 19 en las personas
inmunodeprimidas se pueden vacunar
si se pueden vacunar en este momento la
única contraindicación en algún tipo de
vacunas son el antecedente de alergias
severas pero las personas con ningunos
compromisos se pueden vacunar con esta y
con otras vacunas porque estas vacunas
no tienen virus vivos es decir que no
tienen sustancias que pueden hacerle
daño a una persona y menos supervía es
una vacuna segura para ellos doctor que
consideraciones adicionales deben tener
estos pacientes a la hora de proceder a
vacunarse
bueno antes de irse a vacunar tienen que
agendar sus citas guardar las medidas de
higiene y distanciamiento y al recordar
que siempre se debe consultar con el
médico la enfermedad de estar lo mejor
controlada posible para que pueda
vacunarse una valoración médica previa
en estas personas menos suprimidas
siempre será necesaria para llevar un
proceso de vacunación seguro hasta el
momento se conoce algún ensayo clínico
en personas con afecciones
autoinmunitarias
los ensayos clínicos están en desarrollo
lo que hay hoy evidencia es que muchas
personas inmunosuprimidas han recibido
la vacuna ya somos más de 100 millones
de personas que han recibido la vacuna
de ellas algún grupo han sido menos
suprimidos y no se ha reportado ningún
evento adverso ni mucho menos una
mortalidad es decir que es los estudios
clínicos están en desarrollo pero la
evidencia que hay actualmente permite
inferir que las vacunas son seguras en
la población inmunosuprimidas doctor
estos pacientes estamos hablando de los
que están en una quimioterapia pacientes
con sida con diabetes o con una
enfermedad renal grave están olvidados o
se puede decir que por el contrario los
gobiernos los han declarado una
prioridad
valentina todos necesitamos las vacunas
y aquí en este momento no hay unos mejor
que otros simplemente es que no hay
biológicos para todo el mundo y es
necesario priorizar las personas
inmunosuprimidas requieren la vacunación
la habana recibir prontamente y todos
vamos a podernos vacunar ellos es una
población especial y seguramente estarán
en las primeras fases de la vacunación
el doctor hemos escuchado en las últimas
semanas sobre la eficacia de las vacunas
que ya están en circulación pero se
conoce la tasa de éxito en pacientes
inmunodeprimidos
la principal desenlace es que no hay
mortalidad cuando una persona recibe
cualquier vacuna aprobada para coito no
se muere decoud es probable que las
personas inmunosuprimidas por su
condición o por los fármacos que reciben
la respuesta inmunológica no sea tan
vigorosa como una persona que no recibe
medicamentos pero eso no quiere es que
no se vacuna y que no sea efectiva la
evidencia que hay actualmente más de 100
millones de personas vacunadas es que no
hay mortalidad en esa población mientras
si hay 100 millones de personas con kobe
hay mucha gente fallecida más de 2
millones y el mensaje claro de las
vacunas son seguras se pueden colocar en
personas inmunosuprimidas la evidencia
muestra que no hacen daño y es necesario
que las vacunas sean ofrecidas a toda la
población sin distingo de enfermedades
doctor
hay alguna población adicional para la
que las vacunas puedan representar un
riesgo claro
no en este momento se están hablando en
niños en mujeres embarazadas y estas
poblaciones son especiales porque los
estudios clínicos no contemplan por
motivos éticos este grupo de población
en unos pocos meses tendremos evidencia
suficiente para recomendar tanto la
vacuna en infantes como las mujeres
embarazadas que son también poblaciones
muy importantes durante esta pandemia
doctor yo para las personas con
historiales alérgicos cuál es la
recomendación por ahora que pues hay
estos incidentes que se han presentado
en muy pocos casos
al parecer la alergia de sal alcohol a
los solventes que pueden tender a las
soluciones que pueden tener la vacuna
debe consultarse al médico un inmunólogo
un alergólogo un infectólogo previo a la
vacunación sea tenía antecedentes de
alergias severas
no es cualquier alergia a estos
elementos como el alcohol y por eso debe
hacerse una evaluación médica previa y
se puede usar una vacuna que no tenga
estos elementos doctor pues muchas
gracias por toda esta información y a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros en france24
[Música]